we interrupt this program to be was
found by Muriel in the middle of nowhere
with her husband Eustace Bagge but
creepy stuff happens in nowhere stupid
dog
you made me look bad
[Music]
my name and welcome to
week I don't even freaking know I
sneezed so this is take number two for
me another week another Friday it's good
to be back to your breast this week we
reached 1 million two hundred thousand
subscribers bros which is still it's
still crazy but I'm not arguing with you
so it's okay you both wanted me to
update every week whatever we did I'm
still beyond the point where I'm happy
about where we are so it doesn't really
seem necessary for me but your bro
suggests I probably should mention this
first if when you are watching this
video right now that means I am on the
plane back to Sweden I think I've been
uploading constantly every single day
now three videos every day since I
arrived in Italy which was like a month
ago so and before that I didn't have a
break either because I was at whatever
the thing is the point is I love making
videos more than anything I wouldn't
change doing what I'm doing for anything
else ever ever really but no matter what
everyone needs to break every once in a
while so I'm going to Sweden to meet my
family and meet some friends and just
rip relax and do nothing it's good to be
do nothing I hope you bros want to
forget about me when I'm gone I'm gonna
open some mail that I got from you bros
in this video I wanted to show a couple
of them at least I sneak and abort the
big recording then alright and I got a
letter too so thank you I reached a
million before Nova and that has
restarted the war between us
Oh bracelets
I guess one if this one is for
- temporarily I'll give this to her
thank you Chris because something in it
it's a hamburger candy thank you so much
and it's coca-cola candy thank you so
much
it says I hope you like your favorite
drink and sweet long enjoy what I gave
my favors you know Cola was my favorite
thing barbie is coming for you
Wow creepy Barbie's coming
creepiest Barbie all right and then I
got a gems the spider Oh Jen I almost
forgot about Jen serious now can eat
that that's what he gets for sure
boss why do I have to eat them later
ah Thank You TIA they were sending me
that one of the big ones
it's probably nothing that much because
it's very light why would you send me
this no okay they put something else
inside okay so they sent me this package
with this thing inside with all these
things to make it just sent me a couple
of barrel
whoa amazing look at that and I have a
crazy shirt on don't I yeah oh yeah I
got it
Thank You Mariana you bros all right if
think I told you that I'll tell you so
much
drawing it's I like that you added this
hippie monster that he looks so cute
do you like that yeah I'm Isis like
let's go over there no but how about no
how about no we don't I don't know why
but thank you for these keychain I love
it I will spend all my time doing this
to beautify my name is Beryl hater
enjoy torturing the mini bear oh okay
the mini barrel
I am card I'm sorry about oh I mean I'm
not sorry
here's an awesome picture of the man
himself
good awesome know the barrel and related
stuff take this white barrel oh wait
what are you doing I stabbed four back
why not stab a barrel no you don't stop
we don't stop before
here we are another really big barrel
pawning biking great let's play what is
crazy thing nice shot nice shot baby
you're going to die thank you for that
drawing breath I'm gonna lion
holy look at this it's awesome you
see this she'll have nightmares
I mean I'm beautiful but I was gonna
open this in here it's awesome
it's from Jordan Thank You Jordan I
think that's all the time after today
you bros will not miss me thank you
first of all thanks do you think it was
so much for taking the time and money to
send me all these ladder
I really appreciate it's really funny to
see all the things you do I hope you
don't I hope you bros wanted me too me
too much I know where let me see you a
lot while I'm gone
but until then why not check out some of
my playlists I have a ton of them I
leave the link down down below or decide
I bet there's a lot of stuff that you
haven't discovered yet at the PewDiePie
so are you tell me are you a true bro or
not alright that's that's that's it for
me
stay awesome brothers I will miss you
and I'll see you soon
[Music]
pheromone activate